trump and i are already always for
financial education and all this stuff
but uh desantis is now going to start
using some of our things
to teach financial education in florida
so it's changing
but we're up against the teachers unions
and uh that's what this book manifesto
starts with i'm not against teachers i'm
against stealing my freedom
and the first chapter is the nea
national extortion association the
teachers union the most powerful richest
teachers i mean most powerful union in
america
you know it's interesting because i can
tell you as somebody that lived the last
eight years in california i now live in
in the free state of florida your your
facial reaction was just right um you
know now obviously i'm not paying any
income tax and it's like man you know
what this state is still running and
actually it's running quite efficiently
and freedom is flourishing and business
is flourishing and everyone's moving
here and i have two businesses here and
it's like everyone's fleeing california
because they're just taking 10 at the
end of the year what they're doing with
it nobody freaking knows
that's really tragic because you know i
i believe i left hawaii too
hawaii is more marxist than california
unfortunately good people nice weather
but they don't know they're marxists
they really don't because they didn't
they didn't teach you the difference in
school
but it's a feeling
do you know what i mean don't you feel
different yes
you're totally right i literally feel
different i i'll tell you this i felt
when i was landing in the plane december
17th 2021 landing in the plane when i
landed in florida i felt something lift
off my chest that's how
oppressive i felt that it was especially
the last two years in california yes i
can't believe what's happening dave so i
wrote rich dad poor dad back in 1997 i i
first created the cash flow board game
to teach financial statements
income and expense adjustments of cash
flow
you know and but most people they leave
school they have a high gpa great point
average
but they don't have a financial
statement
strange isn't it
what's more important your grade point
average or your financial statement
and my rich dad always said to me
because he never went to school
because my poor dad was a phd you know
poor helpless desperate and my rich had
said
i'm like 12 years old he says my bank
has never asked me for my report card
yet
so i wrote rich dad poor dad
and now i wrote this book here the
capitalist manifesto
because capitalism starts with a
financial statement think about it
how much income how many expenses assets
are liabilities and what most people
don't realize the u.s dollar is a
liability
against
the
the taxpayer
that's why 1913 the fed was created and
so was irs was that a mistake
probably
i think that would be an understatement
coming from you probably was i mean it
really is amazing that we don't teach in
public schools in the united states we
basically teach no financial literacy i
don't know if you've seen this but ron
desantis in florida just signed
something where they will start making
sure that you have basic financial
literacy and it's like oh okay we're
going to actually teach young people
something rather than gender why'd you
say that because i'm kind of torn now
between trump and desantis you know
because trump and i are already always
for financial education and all this
stuff
but uh desantis is now going to start
using some of our things
to teach financial education in florida
so it's changing
but we're up against the teachers unions
and uh that's what this book manifesto
starts with
i'm not against teachers i'm against
stealing my freedom
and the first chapter is the nea
national extortion association the
teachers union the most powerful richest
teachers i mean most powerful union in
america
maybe they're losing some power now i
mean after two years of covet it seems
like a lot of people have maybe turned
against them i don't know whether it
actually translates into anything but
people are kind of fed up with it
well i think you and i you said it
earlier 10 years ago
we couldn't be saying what we're saying
now
10 years ago i couldn't have written
this book
but today you know when those communists
call uh
parents who question
you know critical race theory and sexual
orientation whatever they're doing
and they call any parent who questions
academics terrorists
i mean it's your kid
don't you have a right to say what you
teach your child
and that and so that's why this the
manifesto book here is
how to combat communism taught in our
schools by teaching capitalism in our
schools
i mean at home at home i teach my rich
dad taught me to be a capitalist at home
not at school
i want to ask you so because you talk
about your rich dad poor dad obviously
do you think it was something beyond
just the education
that defined them in that regard
like do you think it was a personality
trait or
nature versus nurture that a certain
type of person becomes more interested
in relying on a system and a certain
type of person is wired to say hey i'm
going to go get mine beyond just the
education part well that's why i say phd
poor helpless desperate
they need the job they need the paycheck
they need the benefits
whereas when i went to the u.s marine
corps that's a different education
never taught the lead we're taught to
fight we talked to sacrifice you know
nicholson says it best in a few good men
santiago's death while tragic save lives
and you can't handle the truth you can't
handle that and that's the u.s it's
weird that he's now the good guy huh i
love them i i mean i hated it when i was
in it those sobs they were yelling and
screaming at me 24 7.
but when we got to vietnam we were a
fighting machine
you know i flew the helicopter gunship
and my crew chiefs were just as
important as the pilots
you know we couldn't function
without a team
and we killed a lot of people
unfortunately
but we also had a lot of atrocities
against us too
and so when i realized i was in vietnam
for the second time when they're in 66
and then 72
and we're fighting for freedom that's
what we're fighting for not capitalism
then i come back on land at norton air
force base in california
january 10 1973
and i got spit on hit by eggs by all
those hippies from the woodstock
generation
i saw
i saw this book which i read in 1965
coming true i said we're going we're
becoming a communist nation
so what is the best way
i mean my audience watching this
they like capitalism and we can sell
capitalism on them all day they don't
even need it sold on them in a certain
regard but what is the best way to
de-program someone out of the communist
manifesto because that seems to be where
we're at now with a whole generation of
young people
well that's a great question because i
learned to be a capitalist playing
monopoly
ain't that a hard day
especially if you're the one doing the
banking it's pretty easy
just just watch the banker's hands you
know if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of non-stop yelling
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell